when I answered the phone they were like
you apply for the job and I'm like I did
I did
let's see where this goes but I had no I
had no nothing about policing nothing so
when I got arrested when I was eight hey
I'm Dave Rubin and just a quick reminder
to subscribe to the channel and click
the bell so that you actually see our
videos a pretty novel idea I know all
right more importantly joining me today
is a former Arizona police officer and
now the co-founder of the blaze it
movement
Brandon Tatum welcome to the Rubin
report hey thanks for having me man I'm
excited to be here I'm glad to have you
here you do realize that your shirt is
gonna trigger an awful lot of people on
the Internet
well I'm hoping so I'm also I mean I
don't see why we live in America people
should love the flag they should love
the concept of America first so if
they're trigger that's their fault you
must feel very comfortable in my studio
I've got a flag over there yeah big
American flag over there Constitution
Declaration of Independence if so we're
off to a good start
all right there's a lot of there's a lot
of stuff I want to talk to you about
Nora I wanted to have you in here for a
while so first off for people that know
absolutely nothing about you I don't
know it anything about your childhood
upbringing family life that kinda stuff
before we get into law enforcement and
legs it in the rest of it okay well I
grew up in Fort Worth Texas I'm gonna
take this boy cowboy fan by default I
say I mean they're doing this year so I
like them yeah legally you have day is a
cowboy fan you know he's to work at a
stadium so I'm I guess thrusted into the
atmosphere of cowboy nation so but a
group in Fort Worth Texas Texas my
parents was split my whole life all that
I can remember you know and it was
slightly an adversity right because we
had my dad his dad wasn't around my mom
her dad wasn't around
my grandmother uniquely enough had my
mother at 12 years old I was raped and
she had my mom at 12 you know so that
was kind of the foundational idea of
kind of how me and my brother was raised
both parents are really good parents my
dad is a firefighter I'm he's actually a
chief so I grew up in a very diverse
background you know cuz we had a lot of
my mom's side of the family what I would
say he was poor uneducated poor high
school graduation was
like going to college my mom started
family a few of my family members is
doing life in prison so I come from a
diverse type of atmosphere you know you
have the good the bad my dad did a
wonderful job raising us we live with
both my mom and dad went to different
schools private schools public schools
but my high school was a Dunbar High
School Paul Laurence Dunbar High School
named after the famous black poet Paul
Laurence Dunbar it was it was violent
man it was violent
you know people pulling guns on each
other in the parking lot fights I mean
people come off the streets fighting in
the school but what it did do was it
presented a atmosphere where we can
excel in athletics and I say let me go
back to when I was eight because that's
a I was one of the pivotal points in my
life eight years old I got arrested for
smoking marijuana and in a vigorous held
and an eight is when I stopped smoking
marijuana when I was seven we used to
smoke marijuana with my cousins and when
I say they're wonderful people that know
about smoking weed we weren't smoking
joints we were smoking blunts yeah my
older cousins would go buy weed and then
we'll come together we were smoked if my
parents had no idea what we were doing
and so we got busted that time when I
was eight my brother was ten so I mean I
can't even imagine what the mind of an
eight year old smoking weed yeah I got a
knock my son at nine he just turned nine
and I couldn't imagine yeah don't pick
in a weed and smoking it like we were
jeez we were also wait till you get
busted what happened well we got busted
the vacant house I mean they came in
like a SWAT team they hey they pull guns
on us and everything and they put us in
a squad car we went to the detention
center and we initially thought that
they were gonna call my cousin's parents
because their parents really was they
didn't care much man you know they want
we're gonna be in trouble we were never
gonna tell my dad
it was gonna go away but for some reason
they called mr. Tatum there and my dad
is a strong man you know and he came in
there like he was ready to fight you
know he came in there and I'm gonna kill
him I'm gonna kill him I was telling my
brother I was like you know I hope they
leave us in here man bout to get the
whoopin of a lifetime but the thing that
I loved that my dad did and it really
changed my life is that we didn't get
him up here he didn't whoop us he set me
down we were on a ride home
set me down and say it look Brannon if
you don't act with integrity and you
don't change your ways you will never
play in the NBA cuz at the time I want
to be like Michael Jordan I mean that
hurt me more than any woman could and it
kind of set me on a path to feeling like
you know I need to do better man you
know I love my cousins but we can't hang
out with them no more and getting the
trouble that end up causing me to lose
my future more importantly than anything
else how are your basketball skills now
Oh trash trash the best well I hate to
see it I know know it's there typically
this was the this was the year old dream
of this my dream dream died when I
couldn't dribble with my left yeah shoot
from the 3.8 dream die that's okay so
all right well you know what I was
actually going to do some of this stuff
later but so this obviously relates to
the black family and every time anyone
talks about this if you're white let's
say well they're gonna immediately say
you're racist for even bringing this up
and yet I hear this sort of story
so often that what is happening to the
black family or what has happened and
say the last couple decades is sort of
the root of the the problem here yeah
you think that's fair to say and how did
your dad how did your dad not succumb to
that well a hundred percent I think it's
the the root of the problems you know
when you're a young man you've grown up
with no direction where you go who do
you look to you got to look to people
that are influential males in the
community and they didn't have a dad so
you have a kind of a matriculation of
this fatherless home issue going on and
people trying to be fathers without
having examples of what a real father is
so now you're going to gang members and
other dudes like our cousins you know
and we didn't have to because we had a
strong dad which helped us but you still
want to be like you because it's because
they're cooling and this you know it's
kind of trendy what they're doing and it
leaves young man down the wrong path but
unfortunately and I guess fortunately
for me my father was a strong man and I
think that him not having his dad around
really made him feel like you know I
need to do better and my dad obviously
had a little bit of training being a
father because he had to help take care
of his younger brothers and so my dad
probably always had that in him but him
being a strong man him standing on
principles really saved us I'm not gonna
lie you know my mom is great
my mom was way more
than my dad you know my mom was the cool
mom I don't mean and and I hate to say
we kind of took advantage of that me and
my brother didn't have as much respect
for my mom as we did my father he was
strict no cussing in the house back in
the day we had no cell phones
you know he'll pick the phone up while
you're talking to somebody on the phone
he'd be like it's time to go to bed
you know hang the phone up on you so it
was really beneficial and if I didn't
have my dad I would not be here today
well why do you think it's so hard to
talk about that so for example my
parents have been married 44 years now
with ups and downs and good and bad and
all that stuff but I they still live in
the house that I grew up in and I know
that that the roots of that give you
some stability in life doesn't make you
perfect
you're still gonna make mistakes and all
those things but it gives you some sense
of like a consistency in the world it's
so obviously something that that we
should all want or aspire not to say you
can't if you don't have that you're
gonna you're gonna be awful or something
like that but why do you think it's so
hard to talk about this you know it
because when you start to diss or people
take it as a dish to the fabric of who
they are the cultural identity it people
get offended by it right it's hard for
humans for people to take responsibility
for their own action it's very difficult
you know so people like to divert in the
black community culture is what's really
destroying us all right
I mean it's culturally acceptable more
now than it was I don't know in the 40s
50 60s for you to be in a single-parent
home back in the day that's unheard of
yeah back in the day you know having a
family structure was all we depended on
as black people to build we understood
the value of it now it wasn't until I
think late 60s early 70s I think early
70s when that flipped it's beginning to
flip in now it's cool to be on your own
and do you think as a young man all
right you know you listen to the music
that most of us listen to you know
banging a few girls here and there is it
makes you a man you cool you popular you
don't have to stay around with a woman
you can you can hit it have a kid out of
wedlock
most of the do is that there's rapping
most of the potential leaders are doing
the same thing you know so I think it
we've been set off on the wrong path and
when you're confronted with those issues
instead of internalizing and say look
this is our fault we need to get back to
this why are we not marrying these women
that we're having kids with why are
women not having an expectation to date
and to be with a man who's stable and
who can keep provide for them
not somebody that can provide for them
for one night you know not somebody that
can provide flashiness but stability you
know also in the culture stability is
almost viewed upon like you're acting
like when I was growing up and you know
you would do do well in school people
say were you trying to be like the right
man you know if you want to have your
pants right like like it's supposed to
tuck your shirt in and say you know I'm
a married women I'm not gonna disrespect
women I'm telling you I don't know how
it is in every high school around the
world you know in the black community
but I know how Maya was and you you're
getting shunned I remember we had some
guys who were virgins in in high school
and in college I mean you get bullied
there's something wrong with you if
you're not having sex
that's cultural man and I feel like if
that changed we may be able to return
back to saying less value our women less
value relationships it's so interesting
the way the media uses culture sort of
against everybody
did you see just in the last couple of
days there was this piece and Vox about
how Andrew yang should stop using toxic
terms like math and that people should
become doctors because those are
associated with the Asian community
except those are the things we should
all aspire for and they're trying to
make them toxic and that that's the
reverse of what you're laying out there
yeah exactly and and I just that's what
my goal is in life is to give young
brothers a different perspective now
don't get me wrong I used to be sagging
my pants I had gold teeth in my mouth
I got young savage tattooed across my
stomach I got my hood tattooed on my
forearms you know so I understand what
it's like to be involved in it and
understand what it's like to want to be
a part of that culture but I also
understand what it's like to change you
know and it took me finding God to
really take that step and change in a
different direction and I realize man
this is the way things should be we
should be ashamed to be like this when
was your spiritual awakened in 2008 I'll
never forget it you know I was in
college you know I had fun in college
you know my first couple years but I had
a terrible attitude
we couldn't sit across from each other
because we would have probably never met
any time I felt offended by somebody I'm
when I'm ready to fight you know which
which was the detriment of my college
career in football because the coaches
yell at me now I want to fight them I
didn't know how to handle my emotions
well and I didn't care
cursed every word out of my mouth you
know and a lot of things I really did
care about that I care about now race
was very different than me before I got
saved I saw black and white very clearly
I took every kind of studies in college
and it was a period of time where I
hated white people I did I felt so
offended by what they did to my
ancestors from the things they taught us
in college oh yes sir I was gonna ask
you so do you think that was the
intention of the classes because that
just goes across all the the socials you
know I'm not sure bad Dean you know I
didn't feel what I feel today like when
I went to the classes I felt like that
they were just teaching and of course
there's gonna be a level of bias right
if this is your perspective you have the
freedom to teach counter in the
direction you want I didn't see them
over you know propagandizing certain
things I said I go to colleges and speak
now it is clear that they're trying to
intentionally brainwash people into
believe in a certain thing I had a young
guy reach out to me he is the the books
that were required was a books and it
was like anti white man why the black
man is being oppressed I mean I didn't
have those books growing up but or at
least me think I'll get a job after
you've learned that like what do you
doing what is the purpose of it how can
you exist in an environment where you
hate white people but you're only 13% of
the population
how can you exist in an environment
you're gonna you're gonna find yourself
hating almost everybody you around
you're gonna find yourself you know
screwing yourself Radek opportunities
because if you're looking at your boss
as the enemy are you gonna perform well
in your job or you are you gonna be more
willing to try new things or go up in
the ranks are you gonna have the I guess
the spirit for you to visualize success
when all you think is you you know that
you're being oppressed by the white man
so some of that was in me growing up you
know I grew up in an all-black community
I think I never dated a white girl it
was shunned in my community
growing up you date a white woman you
gonna get bullied you a sellout you know
so I had none of that exposure never was
really around white people consistently
mostly around black people everything in
my life was afro century I got to
college and my eyes were open up to a
certain degree because now everybody's
like and it's like 35 loves you know
it's a little more than that right about
a couple hundred but most of us were
athletes yeah
and so I begin to see like you know
white people aren't is evil too is I
thought they were so they weren't
hunting you down they won't understand
you you could you could go eat with
white people and nobody would be so you
know country you were eating with white
people eat with white people enough and
but you know growing up you thought that
was gonna be a lot of animosity yeah I
know like oh they they're mad cuz we in
college you know I'm telling you this is
a real thing were you like what was that
like though really like it sounds silly
even with white people no one's Hyundai
they're like but like that transition as
you were starting to realize it to break
the old mold of thinking like how hard
is that for me man I'm a very stubborn
person but I'm a logical person if I can
see a logical example of truth in
reality then I'm it's easier come to
convert me if you can't show me that
I'll be stubborn to the day I die but it
was really eye-opening for me man
because I you know I perceived that
people were gonna treat me differently I
perceive that people are gonna be
shocked that black folks are going to
college and a we're successful and it
wasn't at all like people in care you
know say so and then I started me on
white friends I'm like man you know
everybody's essentially the same there's
like two people in this world real
people have fake people they come in
different colors and that began to
change in me and then like I said when I
got saved it was like it's like God
imparted in my heart that we're all the
same man so what was that that spiritual
wake up moment well it was a lead up to
it right I mean football wasn't going
well for me I had been going to church
going up you know we were in church but
church one in us right we go to church
and we leave we not listen you know we
listen rap music and doing all that kind
of other stuff we didn't pray we didn't
read the Bible so that's kind of our
lukewarm Christian upbringing and when I
got to college things weren't going well
then I went I said man let me try god
out
I was really gonna rule God out I said
let me see if this is real man because
I'm in a point in my life where it's
kind of a turning point you know I want
to figure out who I am football's not
going well I thought it was gonna be you
know my life moving forward and it's not
happening and I and I'm in a position I
don't know where to go let me rule this
guy thing out and then I can go from
there and I was having visions and
dreams and stuff of God Jesus visited me
and one of my dreams everything like in
a vision and I went to a church I got
invited to a manual grace Apostolic
Church I'll never forget that church and
it just turned to turn my life around
one day I went up to the front I had a
friend with me and she was crying you
know at the altar call she's crying and
you know she wanted to you know find God
and I'm like in my mind I'm like I'm
gonna take her up there cuz she's too
scared let me take her to get her some
soup pray for cuz they pray for you at
the front and when I went up there I
they'll get prayed for and then I found
myself getting baptized and then God
really just changed me man completely
I'm talking about it was a complete
change
I went from cursing every day to never
when I say never cursing again but a
period of time I didn't ever I never
said a curse word now sometimes people
make me mad I mean I said on a TV but
sometimes I do curse but I didn't curse
I think I stopped listening to rap music
completely and my perspective of life
just completely changed I saw everybody
the same it was no more black and white
this racist stuff it was like you know
what God created us all we are our
brothers and sisters in God and we just
have different melanin in our skin this
is kind of a sidebar but do you think
people can have a shift like such a
fundamental shift like that without God
do you think there's a way that some
people can and some people maybe are
more wired to need belief or something
like that well I think that people can
have a level shift to a certain level
right I think God is the ultimate shift
right because I think it's more than
just what human the human
I guess nature can do to change the
things that changed in me were
supernatural in my opinion I can't
explain it I can't explain how I can't
explain why had happened I just know the
experience I had at church and how my
mind completely changed it was it was
like instantaneous mm-hmm when I got
back
and I went down a ward and I came up I
remember telling my friend like I just
feel lighter I don't know what happened
to me something that's happened to me
and I didn't read that I didn't read
through the Bible so I didn't understand
the significance of all of it I
understand that I needed to do it I
understood a parcel of it but I didn't
understand the significant significance
of it until I read the Bible and I said
that's what happened to me now I see and
now I understand that the power of God
can really change you to a level that
you couldn't get you on your own in my
opinion like a sustain like a like a
endurance sustainable level if that
makes any sense it's like it's like more
of an endurance to it to where to the
end of time you can really tap into
something then that's just supernatural
and I see it being subtle when you read
the book that you read the Bible you
read through thousands of years of you
know hundreds of people having
interactions that never met each other
very similar situations they never met
each other they lived in different
dispensations of time different parts of
different countries they had the same
experience that I had in 2008 and it
just made me feel I guess something to
this there's something to it so you have
this Awakening and then you get out of
college did you immediately go in - no
no no I was 2008 I had a few more years
I graduated in 2009 I left football in
2010 so I graduated early so they had my
life changed my career change I was a
good guy you know on a football team I
was a leader things begin to transition
for me I started getting heavily into
church things like that I'm a witness on
campus all of the above
so with that new mentality that new
mindset more of a temper behavior I was
I was taking the gold teeth down my
mouth all of the above I get to the end
of my college career NFL Draft
I did get drafted it was it was
heartbreaking then I was devastated
and there are some reasons behind it I'm
gonna take me all day to explain it well
my career didn't go the way I wanted to
what percentage were you looking at that
morning like were you like 90% I'm gonna
get drafted it was 100% I was gonna get
drafted in it because my agent had
talked to the Oakland Raiders at the
time and they say it to my agent we're
gonna draft him in the sixth and seventh
round he's gonna be the only safety that
we draft
draft because of my athletic ability I
didn't play much at all in Arizona but I
was all-american in high school I was
one of the top players in the nation I
was probably I was could be I was what
we considered a freak athlete and so
because of that lettuce enzyme even
though I didn't play at all the Oakland
Raiders still was thinking about
drafting me they told him they don't
draft me we had a draft party it was on
my birthday huh I mean I've been praying
about this and I said God is gonna make
it happen and draft day came he called
me he said hey they making some changes
I don't know what they're doing they
didn't draft me come to find out they
didn't draft me because the college
coach that they wouldn't talk to right
before the draft
he'd badmouth me and talk really bad
about me and so my agent told me that
that's why they passed on me they didn't
want to take a chance with me given the
circumstances so I was hurt man I was
devastated but I met a guy who's he was
a tremendous mentor to me tremendous the
guy very successful millionaire I'll
give you his first name was John I don't
want to I don't know if he's comforting
me giving his full name but this guy was
a entrepreneurs CEO of a major World Cup
it was like a worldwide company that he
all had its own private jet all of these
things and his daughter played
volleyball with me and my son's mom I
think I could go back we meet her end up
having a child at some point but he his
daughter played with my son's mom and
that's how he met me and so he mentored
me through the process and he told me
something that that was pivotal just
like my dad telling me that in the car
he told me he said Brandon you pursue
football as much as you can with
everything you have and at the moment in
which is not yielding any results you
need to put a X on the counter then move
on and I tried it out for another year I
said man this is not doing anything I
put the X on the calendar while I was
applying for the police department so
let me let me go back because there's
some things missing here during my
college career I met a young lady and we
had a kid together and we weren't
married so we had a kid out of wedlock
which was a whole story in and of itself
because I was in a church I was in the
choir and I had to sit out the choir it
was a lot of things that happened
Church because it is I think it's
important to say so we had a kid and we
were having a son me and her was on two
different pages right I was into the
church we made we made a mistake but I
didn't believe in abortion she on the
other hand was pro-abortion and I
remember we had a conversation about it
she told me look I just want to see how
far along I am and that was our
communication I with the Planned
Parenthood with her at the time I didn't
know what Planned Parenthood was I
thought it was a little cleaning for
women and whatever now I know it's a
little bit of a different perspective
but at the time I didn't know I went
with her to you know to see how for long
she was at the front door of the
facility she said I want you to know I'm
having an abortion and I was hurt man I
was hurt people don't think that me and
manner in these women's choices
situations but they do that's my child
so she was gonna do it regardless
regardless of what they were gonna say
related to timing order right she didn't
tell me nothing she I had already
orchestrated the thing but she waited to
the front door to tell me I said in the
lobby and I prayed and I said God please
don't let her do this you know please
like this is my son I meant I know we
made a mistake with fornication but I
don't I don't believe in making two
mistakes I don't believe in this and I
prayed in there for I don't know how
long I leave get back in the car maybe
like an hour and a half later she comes
out of there crying profusely and I
thought she did it and I said I was hurt
but I said you know she just went
through a difficult thing I'll try to
support her emotionally she came to the
car and she cried she crying and she
told I couldn't do it well I couldn't do
it I got to give her kudos but my son is
nine years old now and so that situation
happened I thought it was it was
pertinent to kind of bring it up so fast
forward to the end of my college career
the football thing she was pregnant and
she was getting ready to have our son
I'm she was close to having our son at
the time being I had to make a decision
put the X on account of a football and
go to something else that I need
something more sustainable I applied for
everything in the City of Tucson I had a
degree
I got I got hundreds of those one day
they called me and it was after an
argument in me at her head I'm sneaky so
we had just argued briefly on the phone
about the engagement ring or something
like that it's nothing major and and I
tell this story because it's always
funny to me how this happened we had a
little argument the night before wake up
the next morning and I get a phone call
from the Tucson Police Department and
initially I thought she had called
police on me like she was mad at me I'm
like I'm done capitalism you know on a
basic argument like this you want me to
go to jail but when I answered the phone
they were like you apply for the job and
I'm like I did it I did let's see where
this goes but I had no I had no nothing
about policing nothing so when I got
arrested when I was eight in the in the
agenda that you feel you know growing up
in the black community feeling like the
cops always have to get you and I did a
ride-along man and it changed my life
officer shot pain changed my life then
that ride-along and that kind of set my
career so you become a police officer
this is sort of a 180 as you just said
from from where you started right what
was the most eye-opening thing about
being an officer it was the idea that I
had no idea what police did and I
thought I did
right watching cops listen to people
online I realized that people that have
never put on the badge and actually
served as police officer they have very
limited understanding a policing period
I mean that I mean limited to like 10%
of an understanding even less than that
if you know somebody that's a police you
may have a little more but I had no idea
completely a different world it's
completely a different job than people
know about emotionally legally you know
the training I mean all of that is it's
completely different and if I got a
taste of that even after all the
training my first arrest was where I was
like this is real man this is real I
really have the power to take somebody's
freedom away and this is not a role
player when we call him an Academy where
the party's faking to be a criminal this
is a real person we really motions a
real life and they can really kill you
too and that was a that was a pivotal
point in our opening point for me what
was it like did you ever go back to the
old community and the guys that were
giving you
we'd as an eight-year-old only saw
you're in your uniform now growing up in
Fort Worth because right you are you
weren't where right you weren't wearing
what there was there was remnants of
that right you had a black community in
Tucson and you arrested people that look
like people that you grew up with act
like people you grew up with like my
cousins and grandma you know and so
dealing with that kind of give you a
little you know flashbacks of what went
on and I got to see it from both sides
all of that horrible stuff I thought
they did to us when we were in a vacant
house how they treated us and all that
stuff I realized that the Mafia was
right they did what they supposed to do
getting the call of that nature not
knowing who to expect knowing that we
died on a day to day basis from Carl
simply like that and that really you
know made me make really really open my
understanding to it yeah what about
racism within the police department
right listen to half the media you know
police departments they're all racist
they're they're looking for racist ways
to incarcerate people yeah it's the
biggest load of crap I ever heard in my
life the biggest load of crap
police if people understood what
policing was you honest you would
understand that it's rare for a police
officer to be actually a racist now are
there racist people in a police part yes
there's racist pastors there's ray I
mean come on we all know we all know
that every walk of life there's some
idiot out there there's still lingering
too hateful rhetoric yeah well isn't it
drives you crazy that you have to
qualify it always with that it drives me
crazy all the time yes there are
homophobic racist yeah there are bad
mean people you cannot exterminate all
them right Thanos could do it but we
can't you know we can't but some people
need to know that because watching the
media every day if you're not an
informed person or you don't
you're not a person that's a leader and
you can lead with your own thoughts your
follower you'll fall into that stuff but
it's very difficult to be a racist on a
police department yeah and one of the
biggest reasons why is because you can't
you can't pick who you serve in the
least racist people in my opinion on a
white police officers they work in a
black community because you put your
life on the line every day for black
folks you are willing to die for black
folks you have to visually see and feel
the pain and hurt in the community when
brothers gay
shot everyday people don't realize that
police are the ones got to put those
young brothers and body bags I don't
care who you are when you see a young
man with his brains hanging out clinging
for life maybe even pleading for his
life
gurgling and blood the age of your son
the age of your nephew cousin somebody
that looks like your mom your
grandmother a young baby that's been
shot through the head from a drive-by I
don't care what race you are man it
messes with you in for people to think
that these white officers are these
cruel evil people that don't have any
sense of emotions or attachments of
human life these people are are the
people that are pushing this rhetoric
are evil and Liars
you put these young people in body bags
every day you go to their mom
grandmother and you look that lady in
the face trying to hold back your own
tears because you could only imagine
losing a son some of these women have
lost all of their children of gang
violence and you got to look in the eye
and you got to be strong for her and
everybody else and say I'm sorry but
he's never coming back and that that's
what people don't understand happens and
I also believe that it's racist in my
opinion to make the projection that
white officers are targeting black
people in the community and one of the
one of the main reasons is that you
would have to assume that all black
people are bad think about this for a
minute if officers are afraid of black
people that means that all of them are
doing something that will lead officers
to be afraid of them that's not true
it's only a few dummies that are
destroying a community what about
grandma now who've been robbed they
called a police for help some woman have
been raped the Econo police for help
officers are seeing another side of
black people that they don't want to
tell you about but they project it so
people can be divided and I think that's
the biggest thing that that bothers me
about it so since you were probably
uniquely positioned in Arizona as an
officer to go to some of these
communities and talk to some of these
people do you think you were able to to
wake up some young kids that were up to
no good and in a way that maybe a white
officer just wouldn't have been able to
as well intentioned as he might be I
figure
young people in black people in general
you know I was considered the black
person whisperer right I'm serious like
we were going cause and black people
will be like oh you know what I don't
want to talk ma'am what a black office
it may come on brother tell you know
tell them tonight they go to jail just
like they would with the right officer
but somehow they feel compassion because
they felt they can identify with me and
a lot of times they were listening to me
articulate to them brother didn't what
you think it is they pull you over cuz
you cuz you black you think they care
about your color your skin they you got
pulled over because you have a suspended
driver's life
oh you're suspending registration stop
jump into that conclusion because you're
creating a scenario of frustration and
and conflict that that need to be had
officer just comes over to you doing the
routine what we call routine traffic
stop and now you you hide oh you put me
on cuz I'm black
this is what that means to an officer
when you say that is that on the races
all right and I don't have any integrity
at all yeah and I didn't waste it all
these years developing building what
I've established and you're telling me
that I'm willing to throw that away and
I have no idea don't care about my
family I don't care about my pension or
nothing because I want to racially
profile you as if I'm dead shallow
minded well you better believe you
probably bout to get a ticket you know
and I think people don't understand it
they start to the conversation I'm very
wrong when they do that a lot of
officers let it go
yeah but some officers that you catch on
camera sometimes they don't take you
like did you also get the reverse of
that though where you go into these
communities and then they'd see you and
be like well this guy's the sellout yeah
why would we talk sometimes sometimes it
would happen more often than not they
felt that they can identify with me one
reason why I think God kind of put an
anointing on me that allowed me to reach
people uniquely black writer and you
know or whatever the fact that I didn't
curse on the job help me reach people
uniquely because when the stuff is
hitting the fan the only person that
sounds does if he got has integrity are
not just integrity but sounds like he's
calm just because I'm not yelling curse
words people attract to me I feel like
God gave me a gift to communicate as
well so I was able to communicate with
people and you know people talk about a
suicide and all kind of stuff what do
you make of just sort of how the media
treats all of the
and that you know certain shootings if
it's a white cop and a black suspect
then we treated a certain way if it's a
black cop and why wouldn't we treat it
differently a lot of times the same
people who are outraged over it one way
then the next day it happens the other
way then they ignore the story the way
we're everyone's playing this really
twisted game with policing right now
there's money and black people's
emotions right we're probably the most
emotional people a group of people if
you want a group in the country war
twice as many white people have been
shot this year unarmed and black people
in America almost every year the case is
that more white people get shot on on
their black people and white people are
not gonna be doing what black people are
doing right I don't see white people
protest them I remember New Mexico they
had a shoot in New Mexico the officer
shot the guy in the back he was mentally
ill shot him in the back I thought it
was ridiculous for the shoot the guy
with the rifle in the back from such a
distance killed him it was a bad
shooting I think the officers got fire
they all got in trouble
white people aren't out here protesting
black people for some reason I don't
know if it's the legacy of slavery that
they got us in the mentality or feel
like we have to defend and be mob like
on certain occasions but we are going to
protest right wrong very different the
man can pull a gun and shoot an officer
and you get shot back we will protest
I've seen it with my own eyes the media
understands that so they don't care
nothing about nobody it's about if it if
it bleeds it leads right they know the
black people gonna act a fool so they're
gonna cover it they're gonna showcase it
they're gonna act like there's this this
outrageous rate of white officers
killing black people which is not even
true at all white officers are you say
white officers obviously in general you
know place in Philly is 50/50 black
right but officers kill more white
people twice as many white people is
black people in shootings where people
are armed they kill more people unarmed
right than black and here's the thing
that people always bring up what is more
white people police officers don't deal
with every single person in the
population they deal with the criminal
element of the population if you look at
but african-americans in America you
know what we make up 12 13 percent of
the population yeah we commit over half
of the murders in this country over half
of the violent crimes in this country so
the bulk of Krim
activity it's coming from a small let me
clarify that 13% of the population is
way overblown number it's more like six
or seven percent of the population
because when you take out old older
people young people women it's mostly
young men between the ages of I don't
know 16 and 35 that are doing the bulk
of these crimes so let's say 6% its
committing over half of the murders and
violent crimes in this country when you
look at it like that police have
overwhelmingly higher presence in the
black community dealing with the
criminal element yet they shoot more
white people than they shoot black
people if you look at the
proportionality of numbers but it's
actually a less likely chance per capita
to junior shot as a black man as opposed
to white people in America and that to
me rules out the idea of the racist
policing in America do you think it's
possible that we're gonna also and maybe
where they're already gonna have a
crisis in policing where good people
forget their skin color yeah which I
would prefer to do all the time but
right but good people who are policemen
won't want to work in black communities
because they know will ultimately be an
unwinnable situation you'll either have
them turning on the black officer like
you and you're the sellout and all that
and the white ones will just be like
well forget this there's no win in this
I could be a great officer for 30 years
like but one weird thing happens that
gets twisted one way or another or
edited or whatever and my career's over
so then you're gonna get a I don't even
know how you call it like a lower class
of qualified people that are gonna work
in the communities that need it the most
right and then people are not gonna
they're not gonna be proactive in
policing we've already seen it happen I
mean if people are now thinking that
we're gonna get to that point you're so
right behind we've done we were there we
were there from Ferguson people don't
realize it the crime rate and these
areas of are skyrocketing officers
proactive policing is going down the
wait listen
police are responsive right they respond
to crimes right if I mean you got into
an altercation I put a gun I shot you
they're not there before I shoot you
they come after the fact but the
greatness of policing if it's done
properly its proactive policing
therefore they've already had contact
with me understood that I'm a danger I
probably gotten arrested for crimes I've
done before before I'll shoot you that
is the way you police but the reason I
mean the
what they're doing today is they're
killing the spirit of officers being
proactive because you go you see a guy
doing a hand in hand people without come
without the experience in law
enforcement to say oh just a hand a hand
no that hand to hand has killed so many
people in the community with drugs and
crime and all this other stuff we see
that we arrest the man hand the hand we
get into a scuffle with them now in
police brutality we get fired
officer sees hand in hand and say I'm
not gonna care more than the community
does because it takes a lot man it's for
you to risk life life and death every
day and putting your family to that and
you want it at the end of the day you
want to get your pension and you lose
your pension over something you did
correctly mm-hmm over something that you
were justified in doing but because the
community became outraged you lose at
all we saw it in Baltimore all you got
to do is look at the stats Baltimore
huge reduction huge reduction in
applicants California huge reduction in
applicants and we've seen this on the
Tucson Police Department and they won't
tell the public because the chief is a
piece of crap but we have to dumb down
the scores because we didn't have enough
qualified people to join the police
department when I was there you have to
make a 75 or above and this is a test
that you can't study for you got to
become out the gate having a basic
understanding now they they I think they
put it down to like 40 percent officers
on an apartment alike and I'm gonna tell
you this any department you can look at
the stats Tucson is a big example when
they did this a while ago you see
officers getting fired out of time I'm
just doing bad stuff they're skipping
over backgrounds it is making policing
in America more dangerous by the
rhetoric that they're spilling which
which is false yeah these are lies that
they're telling you Michael Brown [ __ ]
steals talking about hands up don't
shoot lie Eric garner I will fight to
the death about the justification of use
of force against Eric garner Tamir rice
all of these shootings and all these
things if you're police officers you
understand that these are just the five
uses of force people conflate the two
justify killings is what they call it or
killing somebody versus the
justification of use of force there's a
big difference they weren't trying to
kill Eric garner the dude was fat
overweight heart condition
you use any force against him he's gonna
go into cardiac arrest
he's like a time a ticking time bomb
they weren't trying to commit a kill to
me right
the young kid did he had to pulled a gun
on him he got put in a bad position he
used force against them unfortunately
that one shot caused his death so people
begin to conflate the two we can never
address the real issue because we're not
talking about real problems right and
the interesting thing is of course
you're not defending the incidences
where they're Jenn when they're
genuinely are bad guys but what people
always forget about is that that that
constant threat that you guys are under
you just don't know what's gonna happen
on a knife's edge whether that guy has a
gun or the other thing so sometimes you
have to be what what would I guess
appear to be visually more careful than
maybe the average person would want you
to be what is what I teach you in
academy and I know this is not popular
people probably mad at me for saying
this we get taught an academy and I when
I first said this to me I thought was
the most extreme thing in the world I'm
like are they going too far what they
teach you the academy is that you and
not everywhere where I went in my
Academy yeah you have to be prepared to
kill every single person you interact
with you have to be prepared emotionally
to kill every person that you interact
with because if you're not you're gonna
die you're gonna get killed
and you're gonna get all your other
buddies killed so you have to be able to
have the mindset that at any moment this
person can turn on me whether or not
they're a kid whether or not they're
elderly woman because we've seen a
spectrum of officers getting killed by
all kinds of people you have to be
prepared for that and people don't
understand our perspective this is not a
video game you don't get to hit the
reset button
when you die you die for real and you're
gone forever and unique part of what we
see is that we see people die every day
we see the last breath we see a person
pleading for their life and in the
officers mind it's like I don't want to
look like that when I die I don't want
my family to see me like this guy I
don't want to be at my last breath not
being able to talk to my son on the
phone you need to do the right thing or
I'm gonna [ __ ] meet you I'm gonna win
people pose threats all the time right
you just think about how many I pull my
gun when I was officer four or five
times a week people have guns all right
I didn't escape
I don't know how many times people don't
see that side every officer has their
own perspective about life all right
we may go to the same car you may have
been shot before I've never been shot so
I'm greedy behind here I'm driving in
there no caution yeah the other officer
may have a reflection in the mind of me
and last time I got shot cuz I did this
next time I got shot I've seen a guy
pulled it from here but I didn't react
fast enough they get to the car here you
go fully named shot you give it I'm
saying so the more the more or the story
is that we do go through a lot and if
people understood they will be able to
see these shootings in a much clearer
light all right so let's shift this a
little bit to politics which will get us
to black sit so most of the cities in
you you mentioned Ferguson you mentioned
Baltimore the cities where there are the
most shootings Chicago we can go through
the list of these cities people don't
seem to want to accept this or at least
mainstream media doesn't want to accept
this that these are Democrat ruined
cities right but I thought Democrats
like black people more than you mean
Republicans yeah well what's the problem
here something's not adding up because
it's not true I can't be say it's like
if if the standard is two plus two is
four and you see an equation that said
two plus two is three is something wrong
there
people are not it's politically
expedient for them to evade the issue
and you say well the virtue of having to
be behind your name is cop no it's not
it's the policies think about this who's
anti police Democrats and what are they
doing there cause the police not the act
they're causing police to be the enemy
of the people people aren't snitching
they're not cooperating with police now
crimes aren't being solved but those
things have have issues they want you to
be on full staff they don't want you to
be independent they don't want you to go
out and get it on your own
they don't want jobs to come to your
community they don't want that they need
you to need them so they can win votes
when you say they are you talking about
like literally you're talking about the
political class medical club cause I
believe even for I mean you know enough
about my political level you're as
frustrated as I am with the lefties
these days
most of them I think are just misguided
I don't think they're bad people I don't
think they're really trying to screw
over black people or something like that
the elite do it and they're easy bumper
sticker answers give more money to this
community for
this sounds good get the police out
there police your killer like it all
sounds kind of right but I don't think
the average person actually believes
that no but it's breaking through that
right layer it's not the people right
you can even look at this in a spiritual
sense of a pastor right the people the
lay members are receiving information
from the pastor in in hopes that he's
acting in good faith to project the
gospel right he said he got a degree you
believe him
you're learning from him people in a
Democratic Party the people the lay
members they are listening to these
politicians hoping that they're telling
you the truth about immigration
he said Republicans are all races so
you're hoping that they're telling you
the truth but they're lying to you and
it's the people at the top but it's
about most of these democratic people
that are running for Congress I'm not
even every Democratic person in the
house there are some people that are
like uh never doing more reasonable but
the party line idea the party line
politics is what's destroying people and
it's almost like this look I think I
look at I equate slavery and then the
freedom of slaves to the Democratic
Party today and this is how comparative
to which slaves were on a plantation
they knew what's wrong whatever the case
may be the slaves didn't want to be
there but when they got free wouldn't
the slave master tell them oh wait how
are you gonna survive I got there on
y'all who's gonna take care of you
you're gonna have food we can feed you
we'll take care of you make sure you're
safe stay here in slavery in a lot of
slaves did they felt comfortable they
didn't want to go out on their own and
risk the big bad world become
entrepreneurs be free the Democratic
Party is almost the same similar concept
because black folks need to be free we
need to understand that we can be
entrepreneurs we can be flight attendant
we can do it all they don't want you to
go into this big bad world and fail
failure is only a pathway to success if
you never fail you will never be
successful they don't want you to get
off the plantation they want you to stay
so they can coddle you and then what our
communities become desolate
no real spirit of the community and then
dependent on them right then being the
government you know it's interesting cuz
everything you just said is basically
what Kanye
said about about the mentality of
slavery and then what happened while
mainstream media said you should be in a
mental institution right yeah they they
have to these people are working
together I don't know if his people were
on the same paying money or what they're
working together to put an agenda
mentally I mean all these things that
are run by some of these democratic at
least they have to they can't you can't
you can't go in there they're there I
guess reign over the people yeah there's
a difference between and I'm not saying
every Republican right I'm over Trump
Republican right I don't like somebody
people in a Republican Party and I think
they haven't done much for the black
community anyway their outreach has been
poor to me I've never seen none of it
yeah I never knew they existed until I
decided to you know look on the other
side but when you look at it for what it
is you know the people in the Democratic
Party their focus is on power more so in
the conservative movement are are in a
Republican Party their focus is the
people more so often we want you to be
free less government whatever the
Democrats want power by any means
necessary they will support border wall
they would support strong immigration
reform then when it's not advantageous
for boats they will switch the this they
will switch it in the same conversation
I have with you and act like it never
happened as a person who's new to
politics just seeing Chuck Schumer yeah
and all of it once just advocate Barack
Obama deported the most people in United
States history out of any president and
then they turn in a crowd TV and they
they make up this stuff they tell you if
you come to a port of entry you're gonna
be separated from your family which is a
lie if you come to a port of entry and
you seek asylum you go through a process
but them to verify your solemn seeking
request if you get busted over here are
you trying to sneak through the border
that's when you get separated because
now you're going through a criminal
proceeding they know that but they'd
never tell you because they need you
they need the boats they need power
while having any of these candidates
been pandering as much to black folks
think about this they speaking in
Spanish they own they're talking about
they don't give every illegal free
health care
they want to get housing why are they
nice and we won't fix we're gonna fix a
car go I think I know where you're gonna
fix the school system because we are
being replaced week 13% of the
population
how much do I don't really count now the
Hispanic community or even illegal
legals are coming in by the millions oh
no in about ten years they'll never need
another black person again to vote
because I vote won't count well not only
but not only that but if you get 90 some
odd percent of a groups vote then you
don't have to give them anything if you
know your again that that was the
brilliance of Trump saying well what do
you have to lose yeah cuz all right
we're given this group 90 something yeah
I think it's 94 percent or something
like this ours is 100% it's now on a 90
percentile yeah that's like well then
well we don't worry about those guys we
got it taken care of already
tick you know we got that box checked
and what I preach often is that it's not
about the Republican Democratic Party
you it's about leaving people ain't
doing that for you and in many of these
cases in the inner city you live over in
40 years you're still complaining you're
still ain't got enough you're still
blaming people don't blame the
Republican white man because the
Republican team in your community they
ain't talking to you they're not doing
nothing for you but I am the people who
are there in your community perpetuating
these things stop voting for them you
know I'm not telling you run to the do
your research but you one thing you do
know you may not know what the
Republicans often because you never gave
him a chance what you do know is the
Democrats haven't done nothing and
you're talking about a person in my
whole family a Democrat I grew up
feeling like I was a Democrat and do
when you win when the truth bomb hits
you it's like a ton of bricks
it's a little weird right so we
obviously we obviously you know we swim
in some of the same pools here so the
first time we met was about a year ago
at a turning point man you spoke right
before me yeah it was one of the few
times that I was like oh man because you
were just because you have incredible
energy and the music you went up to it
it's like knock it out of the park and
then obviously I'm a little more low-key
so I was like I don't know if I could
follow that but it all worked out but we
go to a lot of the same events as videos
and I find these people that are usually
Trump supporters but certainly people on
the right they don't care they know
people can't when I talk about it they
they almost can't accept it they don't
care about race they don't care
about sexuality they don't care about
gender they don't care about any of
these issues they're really just saying
let me live that's it but it is hard
like realizing that these people are in
bad like I even still now years later I
go to some of these like some functions
or something and I'll be like I can't
believe these are the bad guys yeah you
know but they're not Isis how I was
raised
Republicans are racist white people
that's how it was and now I'm like
Republicans are like the nicest people
that you know I'm not just saying for
pelicans I'm saying people did a [ __ ] a
conservative spec yeah you know there's
no there's obviously libertarian in it
in it it's flexible on on that part how
are you far-right but I feel like that
people are in and around the
conservative side and viewpoint are the
most generous people are men are the
most realistic people they say well
let's go by the Constitution let's let's
go by what's fair the other side seems
to be more emotional it's not about
what's fair it's not about it's what I
feel if one person have all and they say
just save transgender for example if a
transgender person one person not saying
that we shouldn't ignite as a person's
feelings because the God's mission is to
love everybody but one person says you
know what I need a bathroom they are
willing to say everybody's rights have
to be restructured everybody's feelings
are thrown out of the out of the loop
because one person has a request that
could infringe on everybody else we
don't care because that person deserves
to have because not only that we're
gonna cut federal funding from States
right don't behave a certain way
relative pleasure of the day is for I
don't know point zero zero zero some
percent of the population I don't feel
like this right conservatives will say
well let's see if the person don't fill
it you know they want a separate
bathroom how can we remain it is and
everybody be happy maybe they can
identify a certain way and then use
something that they look like or maybe
not well that's the irony trans people
have been using bathrooms for decades I
never I never in my life I guarantee
becoming guys because they look like
what I mean I've seen trans people girl
I mean man that turning the girls they
got beards and everything yeah I'm not
checking your crotch area man
you come in here you look like a dude
some news that our biological do they
you know they may wear a long hair or
whatever what who cares dude he just
don't be in my store don't be looking at
my stuff we got a problem and I don't
think people do that I guarantee you
that trans women I think that's men to
women yeah they've been going into the
women's restroom forever and some of
them have a conscious awareness to say I
actually present like I look like a one
people don't even know they go right in
arrest you feel comfortable what would
be weird to me is if you look like a
woman
you got breasts everything you look what
are you going to miss restroom yeah I
think that would be more awkward and odd
didn't he wooden one that you actually
match the description they just want to
flip everything a couple months ago I
was in Sonoma I went to I was at a
winery and they had they only they
didn't have male and female they only
had all gender arrestor so you know even
the where you wash your hands is the
same area and this woman came out of the
stall it was he was just obvious to me
that she had just gone number two yeah
we're looking at each other and it was
just it was like something felt wrong
like it was just like why do we have to
be standing here together right so okay
so let's just get let's get this to tip
Lexi because if we go down that yeah
we'll go it'll be all other things so I
mentioned you right before we started
that when I had Candice Owens on
originally this is now like two plus
years ago when she was just a youtuber
with a hundred thousand subscribers or a
near name was read Phil black I didn't
even know her name was Candace when we
the first booked her I said we guys said
to my guys we got to find out her name
at her you know what famous anyway I had
her in for an hour and I just knew in
that hour that this girl was going to
blow up and I'm proud to say that she
sat in here and had a part of that you
know we were just at her wedding a
couple weeks ago you co-founded the
blogs at movement with her the idea that
the basic idea being that black people
don't have to be Democrats really and
Candice always says that it's the least
people she always says people think I'm
so controversial but it's the least
controversial thing that you can say
because you shouldn't have to vote for a
party just because your skin color and
yet here we are right party line is
ridicu
you vote based on the values of your
community and what you want to see
change and that's kind of what the the
premise of Blixen and I think that
people get too caught up in the name
flexing right I know that this is I know
that the name is it means a lot
obviously because the moment is named
after but but the thing is freedom when
I see blacks I see freedom well some
people see blacks they see all you hate
the Democrat it's really not much to do
with the Democratic race more of being
free having a free mind there's
something else out there we for the
longest we feel like it's only one thing
now that we have that we can utilize or
access we just want people to know let
me show you the history of what we've
been doing all this time and it's gotten
us nowhere
here is another perspective think about
this for a minute I believe most black
people are conservative most my people
conservative believe it or not even
black criminals are conservative all you
gotta do is think about it for a few
seconds if you were to sell drugs so
drug dealers I have some of my family
cannot confirm it a knife they still
doing it you have drug dealer selling
weed a neighbor drug dealer they won't
government intervention never drug
didn't want to pay taxes on it on both
drug dealers in libertarians like hey
man you wouldn't hustling all week and
putting your life on the line maybe you
were sick that day
let me give all my drug money and split
it with you is it fair it's never gonna
happen
maimie drug bill they don't have a gun
that don't want their right to bear arms
you know per se to protect themselves
and I know it's a weird analogy but I
think that it resonates because in the
community those things are not just the
criminal element of it but the
conservative ideas right so give me a
wider example than just the black people
as they're criminals widen that a little
bit so would you meet on social issues
though sure about this most religious
people
I think per capita is black folks we go
to church every Sunday we shout and
charismatic churches women we with those
Scripture it's you in a minute we are
the most conservative culturally in my
opinion at least growing up we were that
way my dad didn't let you make excuses
what do you mean you want somebody to
hand something to you you better work
for what you got my dad started at 18
years old on fire department now he's
the chief
my dad didn't put up with that it's
unacceptable you don't want to be a cop
you a strongman these are the things
that grandfather's used to say too and a
lot of people no black communities still
have remnants of that grandma is strong
grandma used to say you see the hail of
jail if you want to act like that and
sell drugs and be that way
black people adhere to that idea the
structure of self rx a entrepreneurs
have being an individual think about
music think about culture black people
dominate culture because we created a
unique idea on our own in many ways that
is that is more a big conservative idea
we don't want to be followers we don't
want people telling us what to do we've
always pushed the envelope as a
community that's to me more of a
conservative idea look at the
entrepreneurs going from drug dealing to
being billionaires jay-z and all these
other people who took advantage of
saying you can turn your life around
and you can be an entrepreneur you can
make it as high as you want to Oprah
Winfrey you can keep naming them I'll
tell you one that people really don't
talk about is its madam CJ Walker who's
the first female millionaire out of any
race in the light in the early 1900's
millionaire well they got pictures of
her with white people driving around in
the early 1900s so we have always
understood the entrepreneur spirit and
for some reason we believe that the
Democrats are their side instead of the
Republicans and we've been confused in
my opinion so back to blessed if we only
understood I think we would change we've
seen we've seen people do you feel it
breaking I think because the other thing
I said you're right before we started
was the day that all the Democrats
started talking about reparations
I called candidates and I said this is
cuz of you yes she caused such a freakin
split where it where it needed to happen
that suddenly the Democrats are like all
right guys we're sorry about some cash
the whole cold hard cash and what's the
number I mean that's the other thing
it's like there's never gonna be a
number that's enough right yeah you know
yeah it's because reparations in himself
is the stupidest idea ever
because how you gonna pay it we pay
taxes the other thing on not let us pay
taxes I'm gonna pay for my own
reparations if I was if I were to get it
think about this how much money are they
gonna give you well they'll tell you
they'll tell you that they're gonna take
it from billionaires and give you how
much though
that's not
nothing people blow that in the weekend
$10,000 is nothing twenty thirty
thousand generational change $100,000
may not be enough and then if you don't
know anything if you're not educated you
know anything about finances
$100,000 gonna last you would I don't
know for months I've had a friend that
had two million I don't think he's got
two million dollars from a settlement
blew it all have nothing to show for it
and that's not what just giving somebody
money it's not gonna help them at all
but that's the swell and also it never
would be enough not just the literal
amount but like okay so let's say you
gave every black person $50,000 let's
just pick up a number well now your two
generations past that right and if the
left just keeps going off the deep end
their grandchildren ago.we
you sold us out for 50 grand true that
was nothing true you know it's just it's
almost the reverse of the way human
psychology actually works right and then
you know you know everybody knows when
you give a person something you just
hand somebody some they don't appreciate
it as much what kind of growth potential
give me a better education I don't need
reparations and money fix these dollar
schools or the money we already giving
you I mean this thing like common sense
to me so you do you see do you think
going 20/20 and you're obviously a Trump
guy yeah do you think there's gonna be
just a seriously massive shift in the
black vote I think it's gonna be a shift
in the black vote I'm not sure how much
the turnout is gonna be if that makes
sense I think a lot of people who live
in a Democratic Party I think that's the
biggest threat to them is that people
may not be on Trump training yet all
right Trump Trump is like on the SWAT
team where you have the RAM the first
person bank to the doors shards going
everywhere it's chaos you throwing
flashbangs in there everything is
confusing and then the people that come
in and smooth after him Trump is causing
a lot of the ruckus I believe that you
may see more of it after Trump the
residual effect of what he has done it
you'll have more people actually going
to vote because it is still a scary
moment for black folks to even say they
support Trump people like me know what
are you gonna do to me people are over
Trump stuff out of town we're gonna do
they're not gonna fight me and that's
not gonna form so they don't say stuff
to people like myself but if you live in
a family whatever it's very difficult
but what I will say is that when I first
started doing things about the same time
Candace did me hurt met when she was
repealed black and you know it was like
ninety ten maybe black folks are erased
you on my page I mean very less than
that now it's like 6040 there's so many
black people in box just flooded in my
hand box saying dude you woke me up I
can't say nothing my mom and never kill
me last year young black it was
something I had to call it a kid's
parent on the phone cuz she didn't want
her son to go cuz it was conservative
thing I said ma'am get a boy chance let
him let him go and she ended up letting
him go to the event but when he got home
they criticized and family want to do
his dad yeah I helped them get prepared
for they have a speech with his dad his
dad one have a sit-down with him like
you know how to be a man yeah if they
wanted to sit down and talk about Trump
yeah it was just the weirdest thing ever
but I have to prepare for it but it's
very difficult but if you look at any of
the pose you know like I mean people
mean I'm not a real poor guy cuz they
say hey Hillary winning and I know she
was gonna lose and she lost but you can
have somewhat of an indication of what
people are thinking on the side of
saying they about twenty percent on Fox
did one around twenty percent
the n-double-a-cp did one if people
never talk about around twenty percent
and I think Rasmussen about thirty
percent what about that moment during
the State of the Union when Trump talked
about all-time low black unemployment
and they showed the picture like are the
Congressional Black Caucus and nobody
applauded it was so I don't know how
other people feel but to me it really
almost made tears come on my yeah it was
a disgusting it's like why do we hate
each other so much I'm not why do they
hate the progression of black people so
much you hate your all people so much
and that's how I see it well they
wouldn't need a caucus much vigor you
know Chris Rock cops need a certain
amount of crime which I know is probably
a little touchy for you but like every
group every group needs a little
something to stay in business and they
know that they're gonna go out of
business if actually we stop worrying
about what what race people are right
and double ACP all these other
organizations are gonna bigger than that
you know al Sharpton holiday will be
unemployed yeah yeah you know so but
they need to do these things but it
hurts people it it hurts them and it
helps people that's on my side because
all you do is point to them and say if
anything whether you disagree with them
or not
when you say that black people are
having the expression of historic low
unemployment at least do this at least
we like right can we get a snap maybe
something you sitting on your hands with
listen they are not a representation of
our ancestors Martin Luther King would
it would be rolling in his grave so fat
he'd be catching on fire he'd be rolling
so hard these people are evilness to our
community they are dead it's almost like
in the Bible the Pharisees and all the
other people who were the leaders and
rulers and they were just doing all this
phony stuff and they didn't care about
the people anymore and it was all about
them and the whole day religious all
this stuff that don't mean anything this
is exactly what the what the black folks
in these hot positions are doing how
dare you help the black community and we
didn't do it you know say how dare you
show us up it's not about you yeah it's
about the young people that need
opportunities so that was a sickening
moment for me man but I'm hoping and
it's like the house of cards to money
showed me everybody have their moment
where their cart falling then I'll go
down my moment was when a Barack Obama
was trashing police car fill people's
moment is watching in Congressional
Black Caucus sit on their hands and be
like yeah I really don't care this is a
game to y'all car filled people are
switching alright so then as a Trump guy
I got I got one more for you to sort of
wrap this all together so for all the
people that hear you that here's so much
I mean your message is so consistent
with so many things that I talk about
about identity politics are frustrated
with the with the Democrats what's going
on with the progressives all of that but
there's still a certain amount of people
and I think it's I think it's a large
amount of people actually that note they
see all of it and they go there's
there's still an aversion to Trump to
whatever it is that Trump is is there
anything you think Trump could do to
change that
I mean he's facing a double-edged sword
right if he's not controversial if he's
not standing up for himself they're
gonna they're gonna they're not gonna
cover him properly and everybody don't
think he's a monster
he has to go on Twitter and be
controversial he has to draw attention
to himself to a certain degree which
some people don't like but people have
to understand how significant Trump is
in this entire big picture right I don't
like everything he does
I love Trump man I'm gonna Trumpster I
don't like everything he does sometimes
I wish he wouldn't get into fights with
certain people some people say it's
necessary sometimes I'm like come on man
sometimes when you know he do some
speeches of whatever I wish it was more
crisp
I wish she was more charismatic in
certain cases but I see the bigger
picture I'm looking at Divi Supreme
Court justices I'm looking at policies
I'm looking at him setting a standard
for supporting law enforcement in this
country I'm seeing him set standards
that I'm saying okay I'm okay with you
not being perfect but you're opening up
so many more opportunities and doors
that the next person that come in maybe
a little more POTUS but you have saved
America in the process I don't expect
people to feel like this man and that
nobody does this anyway they just want
an excuse to be managed from the man is
not a pastor he's not my spiritual
leader so I'm not looking to him for
morality get the diagonal job done
Obama had it all right shooting
basketball he was charismatic he could
say it sounds sweet talk a terrible
bowler though yeah yeah he probably
sucked it both again the Friday golf too
but he was you know he was he was this
cool dude that gets all good and he
sound polished and he was hip and the
rapper's come to the White House but
what did you do based on what we elected
you nothing you almost ruined our
country in my opinion I almost set us up
for complete failure
I don't care what you're doing your
personal life what does the Job
Description say get that done first and
then we worry about everything you're a
second I understand people are gonna be
adverse to it and that's why I said
earlier we were talking that Trump is
the batter around there setting up this
crescendo effect that once he's gone and
another person with the mannerisms in
and in the behaviors of America first
that can articulate it in more of a
compassionate way a more of a personable
way that person all of the seeds that
Trump planted that person is gonna war
them and they're gonna sprout and so I
understand this is kind of the way he
has to be
and they'll just get the job done it's
been a pleasure man I'm so glad we
finally did this and I have a feeling we
will be out on the road we were together
at some point so thanks for coming in
thanks ed and for more on Brandon you
can follow them at the officer Tatum if
you're looking for more honest and
thoughtful conversations about politics
instead of non-stop yelling check out
our politics playlist and if you want to
watch full interviews on a variety of
topics watch our full episode playlists
all right over here and to get notified
of all future videos be sure to
subscribe and click the notification
bell